c'est le pont qui relie le queens à
roosevelt island
c'est une petite île dans le queens avec
vue sur un côté de manhattan
il n'ya beaucoup de bâtiments de grands
ensembles d'immeubles résidentiels
ici les catégories sociales vont des
faibles revenus à la classe moyenne à
roosevelt island
beaucoup de résidents sont ceux qu'on
appelle ici des project
lorsqu'on parle de grands ensembles on
pense tout de suite à la drogue l'alcool
ou prostituées tout ça ce n'est pas ce
genre de quartier ici c'est un peu la
ville à la campagne ou la campagne à la
ville avec un superbe à tous la vue sur
manhattan
c'est un des meilleurs points de vue sur
la ville mais encore faut-il pouvoir y
aller en dehors du taxi comment fait-on
je ne pense pas qu'il y ait une guerre
sur l'île pour haley roosevelt island
c'est soit le but soit le téléphérique
ou vous pouvez aussi marché selon
l'endroit où vous habitez
vous pouvez aussi aller à la nage si
vous voulez
traverser le fleuve à la nage ce n'est
pas très recommandé mais il ya peut-être
une autre solution
[Musique]
en 2002 avec mon associé douglas nous
avons lancé les water taxi pour relier
entre eux les quartiers les bacs et les
attractions culturelles autour du port
et tom fox créa les water taxi
les taxis sur l'eau on ne peut pas aider
les bateaux taxis mais on les a
néanmoins pas en jaune
tous les autres bateaux dans le port de
new york sont blancs ou bleus et nous
voulions attirer le regard des gens
quand j'étais enfant j'adorais les
checkers que les taxis jaunes
on a donc décidé de peindre les bateaux
en jaune avec le damier blanc et noirs
madiot prude pro bateaux et les gens
pensaient que nous en avions 10
et maintenant que nous en avons tous les
gens pensent que nous avons 30
car il les voit partout autour du port
[Musique]
nous avons dix endroits différents où
vous pouvez monter ou descendre du
bateau pour aller au travail ou visiter
la ville les water taxi permettent
d'éviter les embouteillages
tom forte n'a jamais été à court d'idées
pour approcher l'homme et son
environnement
[Musique]
j'avais vraiment la main verte quand
j'étais jeune je transformais des
terrains abandonnés en jardin le bateau
accosté dans le queens c'est un endroit
où il y avait un terrain abandonné alors
j'ai demandé à la porte authority si on
me laisserais construire une villa et
tom fox créa water taxi beach ils m'ont
dit oui on a donc apporté mille tonnes
de sable sur ce terrain on a installé
une tente un terrain de volley-ball un
bar et c'est devenu une attraction
populaire pendant la journée c'est un
endroit pour les familles et le soir les
jeunes branchés arrive il ya de la
musique on danse c'est un endroit super
[Musique]
et oui pour faire une plage il suffit
d'avoir du sable et de l'eau il ne reste
plus qu'à prendre son pied
[Musique]